I just I've been really depressed lately
very very depressed interesting almost
like suicidal almost [ __ ] out of here
real talk I mean great and all Bobby
that you have your depression but life
is not that bad for you bro bro think
you have a roof over your head you have
so many things I'm sorry I was suicidal
when I was born
yeah so was I guess what I've been
actually locked up for trying to kill
myself three [ __ ] times I've been
institutions myself too [ __ ] no you
were in rehab that's not yeah I was in a
high school gym - but yeah yeah
shouldn't you shouldn't say it's so
blase without alright I'll treat you
I'll restate what I said okay good I
feel really bad
and I want to cut myself with razor
blades I mean if that's what you're into
yeah yeah I've never really been a
cutter myself I was a huge cutter why is
that a thing I was a huge cutter from
the age of 15 through 19 and every one
of the reasons why I have the tattoo on
my forearm is to cover the scars oh yeah
I got really real real fast I used to
punch my belly you were fat yeah yeah oh
my god band camp was the worst freshman
year oh [ __ ] I don't talk about it no
tell me let's talk about your fatness
freshman year at band camp a lot of its
kind of Kay's before I knew how to be
funny so like people would make fun of
my fatness and they'd always call my mom
like it always come on mom like a porn
star the fat porn star they used to
watch her go
yo Gilbert true black fatties I loved
mom's titties duck your fat titties and
I used to like I used to laugh he's like
that's good oh dude anyone talking about
my mom like that they were [ __ ] die
bro yeah I don't know what to do it's my
white guys against me oh I hate white
people George and that George he's pink
sofa band camp I remember they used to
say it so much but I would laugh and
they would laugh so I thought it was
okay but every day after at night I
would go to my room yeah my roommate
wasn't there at band camp I just cry
just thinking Oh funny
I said cries oh God
there's no dude let me say this right
now if I die and I go to heaven if there
is a heaven if there if there's our like
a room where you can see replays of
people's lives he would go back that's
the first thing I want to watch I'm
gonna hate God can I see the replay of a
Gilbert pointing a stomach when he was a
kid did you do this when you were really
fat would you sit in a tub and then lay
flat to see like so your belly would be
really flat and imagine that you'd be
skinny one day I have a lot of fat
friends who did that what do you do so
my yeah we all think are weird I have
fever brain done that you sit now none
of me not me so I had okay my ex that I
was with for a really long time previous
to Bobby he used to be a fat boy before
he became really really good-looking
like I mean obese like he was probably
he said he's about 511 but he was
probably about 260 so he's a big big boy
yeah yeah so he used to cry and tell me
the story about how he would sit in a
tub when he was a fat boy and so like he
would sit flat and imagine you know cuz
your stomach would be flat when you lay
down right and he would sit and cry in
the bathtub and hope one day that he
would his stomach would be flat like it
was when he was in that position and I
thought to myself and he used to tell
him he's like yeah I think like all fat
people do that so I believed that I
believe that nobody had issues that's
his own thing and so he I think he just
ended up doing meth and lost weight Wow
I would do this as a kid I would put
like my fingers over my eyes and make
him round her to see what I would look
like yeah that was I wasn't a [ __ ] oh
my god or do a lot of Asians do this
where you you use it like a pen or a
pointed tip and then you run it across
the your eyelid so you could put a
crease on there for about like 20
seconds it's a weird thing that thing
where like you know as a kid why people
would say or just anybody
it was generally Wyatt yeah and there we
go you know your eyes your Salani and
they would do the thing with like that
and John being Chong and then you would
get really devastated hurt yeah you
would go home and would try to explain
to your parents like they made fun of me
like your dad would go I don't know
you know right and yeah but like they're
making fun of me and you would cry
coming home and like then you would have
this deep resentment you know me you had
nowhere to turn either as a kid yeah
there's no you can't turn on the TV or
go on the internet back in the 70s
that's the one out it happened to me
in the 70s you know was there a time you
ever eat Ali ated against a bully no I
mean I was gay I remember this guy named
iron-containing
[ __ ] it art it was art right he was to
pick me up you know I mean and dunk my
head in the toilet I thought that was in
movies no no that was real you actually
got yeah yeah was it called I don't know
what that was called swirly so yeah yeah
yeah yeah and they would flush the
toilet my head would be in there and I
would cry you get arrested for that now
that's a [ __ ] hey yeah but back then
it was like a thing
Wow yeah and then like I remember I
lived in Minnesota it was really snowy
in every one of the kids Eskimo and they
would throw snowballs at my face yeah
yeah used to call me an Eskimo damn
that's not like that not even like the
soft kind with the ice in it [ __ ] what
can I tell you what happened to me as a
kid I just remembered this boy I was in
a coma bro how would you know oh wait I
think he did tell me yeah my mom my
parents even come back pack it up
I mean it might happen in my middle
school not miss an elementary school
there was a lived in Minnesota and there
was a hill that went down and on the
bottom of the hill there was like this
slope and then like a jump and then
there was a pole like where the jump
yeah was right so these kids put me on a
sled and they pushed me down the thing
against your will against my will and I
went off this thing and then I my face
hit the pole and I went tumbling down I
fell on my back and the next thing I
know I'm in the hospital that's all I
remember
and my face was ripped up oh yeah that's
not a did you know no I was knocked out
for like a day or something you probably
concussed to me that's a coma
that's terrifying to just wake up in the
hospital was a 12 hour coma that's
pretty awful and I woke up crying they
try to suit no they didn't do nothing
nothing no because back then the white
people ran it agents don't ever wanna
just you know ever
LaRose like that would you be just don't
ever one they don't want to rabble
rousers they want to none of that
so everyone going back to school and
then avoiding those kids that did that
oh my god yeah it was scary that's the
kind of [ __ ] that had to go through and
then that's when I was molested too back
then
Minnesota was not a good place for you
though it was dark so not good for
Asians no my even my personal life like
when my brother was seven and I was ten
the reason what my brother and I shared
the same room and my mom came in to our
bedroom and like 3:00 in the morning and
she she opened her mouth I remember her
mouth was like bloody and she was
missing a tooth Oh cuz cuz my dad
punched it out and then remember us
barricading the door trying to get my
dad not to come in the room and he came
in there and he beat up my mom he hit us
a bunch of times and then he passed out
he was drunk yeah but that was like a
daily occurrence bro yeah yeah so the
kids Eskimo the Down syndrome molester
the cooking at the coma thing the
[ __ ] my dad being violent and all
that was like a traumatic childhood yeah
yeah what do you think you would have
been like if you didn't have a traumatic
childhood I'd be a preacher you would do
you think would not be preaching many
God your core has always been rotten
from the start I think that I used I
remember like I used defense mechanisms
a humor as it humor defense mechanisms
yeah same here so what happened was like
my friends would come over and I would
do like a comedy show I put my parents
clothes on I would do like sketches and
stuff like drag now what just do
different that we would do this thing
called make me laugh or if they would
laugh at me I'd get to hit them with a
ruler in their hand like do ten right so
it makes them not want to laugh which
gave you the challenge to do it it was
really fun just why you do that a lot
here yeah I do it no yeah and I do that
and then um and then we used to do this
thing on what we do this thing called
road warrior what's that
we take skateboards and there was like a
hill right oh this is when I was in San
Diego now but they were used to so there
was this hill
and we would all ten people kids would
have like baseball
and like football helmets in padding and
we would go down this hill and we try to
knock each other off to see who can get
to the bottom the hill first sounds
[ __ ] fun that's like we used to do we
used to go ice-blocking do you know what
that is this is already in America and
my Korean friend actually introduced me
to it who's my best friend now because
she's is the rugged [ __ ] she doesn't
want Jessica she's one girl who's what
do you want to eat yeah yeah you just
buy a big block of ice and you find a
steep grassy hill and you just bomb it
you just hope you don't die on your way
down and we would get cut up we would
get it but it was so fun it's just so
fun you know what I mean like to to to
go home a little bloodied that little
sore a little itchy from the grass I was
fine yeah I used to I stick a BB gun and
there was a guy that was a paraplegic
help come on man
no you better not have shot him forget
it no we were on the roof yeah if he was
a dick he deserved it no he wasn't
the paraplegic he was a nice kid never
get caught and we'll be on the roof and
then he was in his backyard he was
sometimes be out there too sitting there
in like a like a chair a wheelchair yeah
we've him in his face a couple times we
did that we hit it it wasn't that
powerful but what would he do like I
think it's like bird poop let me cry it
would hurt on a cheek
[Music]